F
PUNCTUATED. TT' HEREILE AEG TONT
IN P T WER O RIGHT OUT SPA MILL
HAD TO DO AS TH DOWN HERE
O A RADIO. AY IEIR B NAY L THES
HAVESEDENTBEOR
NA SHE'S NOTICED A
BADR. THE CITYAS. LIFEEEHOICE.R.
THIS WEEK, AND THEIGHE IN IN TE
BONES THAT UKRAINE BE
AIMING SOUTH TSIA. IT'S QUIET.HN
LO BECAUSE I'M GOOD
THOM
CLOSE FLY
THESE OPEN FIESO HE OTHER AHETHS
COUNTER OFF O
THRGET. THE CARSE
BUILDINGSES AND
OFFENSIVE OR JUSTHI NEVER DO ITS
SI BIND. IT'S N NM
HAVE SIMILAR EXPERIENCE.
90 MINUTES, EACH ONPARACHUTES DT
REPEAT. THEAND WAHI WILL SOE
NOW IT REMAINS UNCLEAR WHEN THIR
NS MAY BEGIN. THERE
INDICATIONS HAS BEEIVOU T AREAS
VEHICLESHE FOR
PPEN, IT
UN, IT SO VIT
UKRAINE TO SEIZE THIS MOMENT T M
WAY ANDOIANS AHEAD OFEREMATE LAS
ON T DATIONS THAT IT WILL BEDECD
.  RHTU MM UKRAINE TONIGHT
WAO OWTIRED AIR
FO C LEIGHTON
FORMER CIA
OPERIO I JUSART WITH THAT RUSSI,
RIGHT, ANDY'
BELGOROD DAY W
GOING TOIGHT? AND IT A BIG CITYA
LE LIV THERE.
YOU'RE A FORR. DID YOU THINK WHN
YOU HEARDBOUT THE RUSSIANS
TRUTH, I THOUGHT, HOW COULD YOU
MAKE MISTAKE LIKE THAT? AND IT
REALLY INTEIN
BECAUSE WHAT THEY' IS'RE US TERY
, OFALAUNCHED AREAND GET ANDTAR
HORRIBLY WRONG IF IT WASN'T A AR
TH PTIDEAUTULYCTED AAJ ROAD
INTERSECTION THIS IS,
A KEY IND THE
IF THEY HAD DONE P PURPOSEFULAS
T? F WHAT PUE? BE TO SABOTAG T
EFFORT TO INDICATE THAT THERE'S
THAT TO.SEEWITH T
IFN A. IT'S
PRETTY INCREDIBLE. E T,
THIS SAY ABOTY. YEAHD OF OE RELS
I MEAN, IF IT ISIG THAT. IEAAS N
LI ARE OTHER
POSSIBILITIES. WE HAVE
TH. YOU KNOWY YICROCHIPS FRE
ANYTHING THAT'SAKE A SMAHEY CIED
IN WE HAVELY
SEEN SOME RDITY IN
E CRCROSS THE RUSSIAN
MILIECOULD HAVE SIMPLY AN INCOMT
OR  SOME OTHER PARFRY THAT CAUS
N, IT'S
THEY THER
WORRYINGNG AND N KIDS IN
THOSE SCHOTO DUCK C OF R
TRULY IS.O MAGINEM SOLTHIS CONTE
DIFFICUL AUITINGTEVE JD THOSE RI
NE
TO THEY'REUT YOU KNO IT'SG NOW U
HANDCUFFED TAKEN TO MILITARY DAR
ENLISTNT OFFICE BEC HDEFERMENT D
THEN HE JOINS, HYS OUT OF
COMPLETE P PRESSURE
W DO UNDERSTA THIIS
THENL
IN OTHER PLACES IN MOSCOW AGAIN
, AND THAT IS SFI
PI DOES  T
OUT PUTIN'S
L I THINK PUTIN'S ARM
ARMY AND YOU KNOW, HIS STEVE
INDICATED WITH BECAME, COMES TOI
NEED REPLACEMENTS QUICKLY,
O THEM IS TAF PEOPLE IS M AIBL,
AND THAT'S THAT'S AT
H E SO, STEVE,
TODAY THE
GH? THE SDOF PESKOV
HA IN THE
WAGNER GROUP SERD ASOT C
THIS, BUTS SAY TO
YOU THEAT GROUP GAGOSIAN
AND PUTIN IF PESKOV SON WAS
CHAPR TG WITH WAGNER? YEAH
CHRONICLESOU WILL. SO YOUKOVOW,
VERY HIGHKING GUY. WE SEE
ON ALL TIME,
ANYTHING OF
OF VALUUTIM A
LOT. CLEARLY CLOSE TO THE
KR TBEEN
QUS GOING TO
HAPPENITOF,
ING AGE IN
IAT
DEFENSIVE ABOUT THIS. SO NOW
THERE'S THIS PRECAUTION. C OH, E
. IT AS TO
WHETHEIT
CRIMIN P RKNOWCENDING INSID
SOME OF THE LEADERSREHAYING TO E
LIKE, LIKE PESKO, IF SO, MEAN, A
TRE ABOUT HOW HOW YOU PLAYATDAG
DIFFICULTS